[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta mogolla estaba con
nosotros esta mañana de viernes en el
estudio Marta bienvenida buena mañana y
abrimos la revista de prensa con los
medios internacionales que llevan hoy en
sus reportes el escándalo de corrupción
que cae sobre el presidente de Sudáfrica
siltramajosa por tener guardada una
buena suma de dinero en una granja este
dinero fue robado pero no fue declarado
no Marta sí Raúl buenos días vamos a
empezar con roiters que hace
precisamente un explainer acerca de este
caso no el denominado caso fala fala que
es el nombre de la granja de recreo del
presidente sudafricano ciril ramafosa el
explainer de roiters un poco las claves
de cómo ha ido gestándose este escándalo
que tiene a ramafueza bajo presión
cuando estaba además a punto de
convertirse en el candidato presidencial
de su formación política de Cara a las
elecciones de
24 el miércoles se publicó una
investigación en la que se encontró
evidencia de que el mandatario podría
haber cometido un delito en relación a
más de medio millón de dólares que se
habría encontrado en el sofá de su
granja en fala fala esto es un doble
escándalo Porque además civil rama fosa
combatió duramente para echar a su
predecesor a Jacob zuma que había sido
precisamente o había estado manchado por
corrupción Cómo empezó todo pues en
junio el ex jefe de espionaje Arthur
Fraser denunció ante la policía al
presidente sudafricano por presuntos
delitos de lavado de dinero
encubrimiento y corrupción de ese robo
de dinero en efectivo ya que unos
ladrones allanaron la granja del
presidente y encontraron más de medio
millón como decíamos de dólares
escondidos en este sofá esto dio inicio
a una investigación que planteó dudas de
si el presidente como decía Raúl había o
no declarado este dinero rama fosa
siempre lo negó y se mostró y no O sea
se declaró inocente pero la evidencia
gráfica sostiene que ahora la oposición
pueda iniciar un juicio político contra
él Qué dice business text sobre esto el
business es un periódico de Sudáfrica
sostiene que los hallazgos de fala
no dan ganador a nadie no porque no solo
implican al presidente sino también al
partido de gobierno y a la agenda de
reformas que planteaba el gabinete de
Rama fosa no Al Calor de esta
investigación Fuentes citadas por este
medio sostienen que civil ramafosa se
estaría planteando dimitir antes de que
iniciara ese hipotético juicio político
y esto genera mucha inestabilidad y a
pesar de que este presunto caso de
corrupción en el gobierno ha impulsado O
sea a pesar de este presunto caso de
corrupción el gobierno de ramafosa ha
impulsado grandes medidas en cuestiones
de telecomunicaciones acabando con
monopolios y de diversificando la que
dice the economics Marta el día que uno
me sostiene que un sofá repleto de
dinero pone en peligro al presidente de
Sudáfrica y da un poco la versión de
ramafosa que defiende su inocencia y
dice que el dinero en el sofá
correspondía a la venta a la venta de 20
Búfalos de mala calidad a un empresario
sudanés en la Navidad de 2019 ahora que
ya tenemos todo este contexto Martha
vamos a ver entonces cómo lo titula la
prensa sudafricana sí Raúl vamos a hacer
un repaso rápido por las dos principales
portadas sudafricanas empezamos por el
Citizen que titula las decisiones
difíciles de Siri vemos en una viñeta el
presidente rama fosa que bueno sostiene
un paraguas con el nombre de la granja
no fala fala y vemos no esa lluvia de
dudas En referencia probablemente al
futuro político no sostiene además el
Citizen que la investigación en su
contra enturbia las aguas del presidente
cuyas son dimitir asumir el juicio
político o enfrentarse a la justicia Por
otra parte el diario Start titula a
partir de aquí todo cuesta abajo también
vemos la imagen del presidente y dice
que hay crecientes llamados a su
dimisión cambiamos ahora de tema porque
tras las declaraciones a favor del
nazismo El rapero kanye West sumadas
también a otros comentarios antisemitas
que ha venido haciendo en los últimos
días nuevos semanas meses incluso la
creación de su imagen pública Marta es
cada vez más evidente y vemos o como lo
reseña esto la emperador sí Raúl vamos a
empezar primero con lo que ocurrió en
esta madrugada la envió el titula elon
musk dice que kanye West ha sido
suspendido de Twitter El Magnate ahora
presidente de la red social
eliminó la cuenta del rapero por
incitación a la violencia después de que
kanye West ayer publicara una esvástica
en medio de una cruz estrella de David
Perdón es la última de las mil polémicas
que envuelven al rapero después de hacer
repetidos comentarios antisemitas o de
exaltación al nazismo en las últimas
fechas ayer concretamente también
participó en un programa de extrema
derecha de Álex Jones que es un teórico
de la conspiración de extrema derecha
que debe más de mil millones a familias
por daños morales que a Víctimas de un
tiroteo masivo y dice que le gusta
Hitler y que además de amar a los judíos
también ama a los nazis recientemente
fue criticado también por reunirse la
semana pasada con el
supremacista blanco Nick Fuentes en una
cena en mar al lago donde También estuvo
el ex presidente Donald increíble ya
rápidamente para finalizar Marta box.com
y político que dicen estos medios el box
dice que Kenya West y el fin del
antesimetismo del guiño guiño no este
antisemitismo de tapadillo la evolución
del rapero hacia ser el más famoso de
Estados Unidos a envalentonado a la
franja más antisemita del país poniendo
en riesgo a la comunidad judía en gran
medida los ataques antisemitas han
pasado inadvertidos en partes del
partido republicano aunque las últimas
fechas sí se han pronunciado contra él y
político dice que se tienen que o sea
Partner esta red social asociada a la
extrema derecha en Estados Unidos ha
cortado toda opción de compra para kanye
West que habíamos mostrado su interés en
comprar esta red social Marte como
siempre Gracias por toda la información
de esta revista de prensa finalizamos
semana nos vemos el lunes por supuesto
con más así que a disfrutar sus días de
descanso Gracias Raúl gracias